see what you've got to do folks when it
comes to this FICO score stuff and
people run around mouthing about that
stuff all the time
oh my god they have done such a good job
at FICO of making you believe that that
is an actual indicator of your success
your FICO score is not an indicator of
your success all you've done is
successfully pay payments and interest
to the bank it's the only way you get a
FICO score I've got an 880 well I'm
sorry that probably cost you about a
hundred grand I mean really you can get
your aunt could die tomorrow and leave
you ten million dollars you know what
that would do to your FICO score nothing
because your FICO score is not an
indicator of your net worth your boss
could walk in this afternoon and raise
your income to a million dollars a year
you know what that would do your FICO
score nothing because a FICO score is
not an indicator of financial health
it's not an indicator of a big income
it's not an indicator of a big net worth
it's not an indicator of a big
investment portfolio a FICO score is an
indicator that you've borrowed money and
paid it back a lot and the higher your
FICO score it means the more it means
the more you've done this over and over
and over and over again
so this worshipping at the altar of FICO
represents stupidity on your part stupid
because you're using a false measure of
success it is not a measure of financial
success unless you consider paying lots
of interest and payments to the bank
success it's the only way that your FICO
score develops and case in point is if
you never borrow money you'll never have
a FICO score case in point is if you pay
off every single account and close all
of them and you have a net worth of tens
of millions of dollars and you make a
bazillion dollars a year and your
FICO scores zero that's me by the way
okay I have is zero FICO score I'm
number of money in twenty years all the
accounts are closed they're not just
zero balanced they're closed I don't owe
a soul and haven't in twenty years
and plus over twenty years and so I
don't have a FICO score but here's how
stupid our culture is I can wander over
here to the local apartment complex with
some little 27 year old apartment
manager who reports to somebody I live
in Nashville and they report to somebody
in New York or in Atlanta and I fell out
an application or in an apartment and
because I don't have a FICO score
they're there they're thought train is
so backward and stupid
they won't rent me an apartment now I
can write a check and buy the whole
freakin complex but I can't rent an
apartment there see that's how stupid
this is and how culturally backward it
is so if your goal is to buy nice
furniture for the bank lobby then run
your FICO score up if your goal is to
make sure that the windows are cleaned
on that hundred storey tower in the
downtown skyline of your city and that's
a bank tower if your goal is to make
sure the window washers there get paid
then run your FICO score up if your goal
is to make sure the stock at general
motors are forward or Lexus that their
stock price goes up because their profit
has increased because they funded more
car loans and made interest on you then
run your FICO score up but if your goal
is to change your family tree and become
very wealthy and outrageously generous
if your goal is to have tens of millions
of dollars in order to make sure that
your family generationally is
shifted and that you have the ability to
be unbelievably outrageously generous if
that's your goal then screw FICO why are
you giving them money why are you giving
banks money to run up a false measure of
success it's not a proper measure of
success but all these dadgum broke
financial geniuses that work with you or
that'll be a Christmas dinner in your
family we're here to protect your FICO
score oh my god you're listening to
stupid people who are broke and they ran
their FICO score up they got no money
but they got a big score which says
they've been playing kissy-face with the
bank a lot that's all that score says
now you can fit you cannot find any data
to support anything except what I've
said is the truth go study FICO look at
the history of the organization look at
the algorithm and the way it's built
well you can't get a house without a
FICO score says a [ __ ] of course you
can get a house without a FICO score
there's two possible ways one is you
save up and pay cash for it which people
do believe it or not and two is you get
a mortgage company who actually knows
how to write a mortgage without a FICO
score not all of them do a lot of them
are so stupid they only know how to look
at one number who monkey can make this
loan make then I got the number who will
know if he's got a job but we'll give
him a dadgum loan but if you know if you
get a mortgage company knows how to do
manual underwriting you can get the same
mortgage that high FICO score boy can
get the exact same mortgage if you want
to go get a mortgage so quit believing
the lies that are out there and
stumbling around in your stupidity and
wondering why you're broke it's
ridiculous it's so aggravating
ah it's gone on for so long too
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]